hi everybody i'm nancy o'dell and et is
taking you behind the scenes
so they should hire me as a full-time
model on prices right i'm just saying
it's really fun i mean everyone gives
you so much energy when you're here on
set i didn't realize how exhausting
smiling is
like i don't know how drew does it like
he has to do two shows a day then he
comes and he has to rehearse with me
all night actually i just i spun the
wheel about a dollar on the right i
spent a dollar how about that like
my very first time was always my dream
to spend the prices right wheel and i
got i got a dollar ever since i met her
that's all she even talked about when i
very first started she goes can i spin
the wheel and just come to the front
start to spin it here yeah i actually
want to play the game but yeah well only
when the next time we have celebrity uh
yeah
i'm not sure if i would be great i don't
remember the last time i went grocery
shopping but i would try i've we danced
the number already like half speed
and i'm already like no it's okay it's
only thursday though it's only thursday
and i like you know his hectic schedule
i seriously still can't believe that
you're even signed up for this show
you're doing a great job i might have an
awful injury on monday morning
what i like is i know that she's going
for like the best performance we can get
every every week so it's nobody i i
really didn't want somebody who's gonna
go like oh that's good enough let's just
do that you know so she's really good at
like we're trying to do the best we can
every week on the show stay in it as
long as we can